[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de faire une
expérience avec vous une expérience de
financement participatif de projets ce
projet c'est le projet d'eric eric est
un boulanger à genève
eric nous fait le plaisir et l'honneur
d'être présent parmi nous aujourd'hui et
j'invite eric à se lever je vous invite
tous à à l'applaudir merci alors éric il
y a quelques années a rencontré une
difficulté il a dû changer de local et
pour changer de local il a dû financer
des travaux et pour financer ces travaux
il n'a pas eu accès aux financements
traditionnels
face à cette difficulté j'aimerais qu'on
expérimente ensemble le financement
participatif et le fait de financer eric
eric a besoin de 15 mille francs et
aujourd'hui nous sommes un peu plus 300
personnes dans la salle donc si nous
prêtons tous 50 francs à eric on
arrivera à financer ses travaux
en contrepartie eric nous propose pour
nous remercier de l'aider de nous
rembourser non pas 50 francs mais 52
francs dans un an
aussi j'aimerais vous sollicitez savoir
si vous êtes d'accord de financer et de
soutenir eric si tel est le cas je vous
invite à lever votre pouce en l'air
bravo alors c'est un modeste succès par
rapport à ce qu'a fait eric réellement
et vic en 2011 a été confronté à cette
situation et n'ayant pas de solution il
a décidé de mettre sur le comptoir de sa
boulangerie des contrats de prêts pour
proposer à ses clients de le soutenir de
l'aider en lui prêtant de l'argent avec
à peu près les mêmes conditions que
celles que je vous hais
il vit qu'à espérer lever quelques
centaines de milliers de francs il a
levé plus d'un million de francs pour
être précis 1,65 million de francs et
depuis ne se finance plus que par le
financement participatif
c'est un beau succès ce que j'aimerais
qu'on arrive à comprendre ensemble c'est
comment et pourquoi
eric a réussi à faire ce financement
participatif
tout d'abord eric avait une communauté
il a plus de 1000 clients qui viennent
régulièrement chez lui avec passion
acheter ses produits qui viennent pour
soutenir la cause
c'est à dire continuer à avoir un
artisan dans leur quartier qui fait du
pain qui lui font confiance
eric leur a composé une contrepartie
ce sont les quatre c'est d'une campagne
de financement participative réussi et
pour chaque campagne on doit avoir ses 4
c le problème c'est que malgré ce succès
eric n'a pas pu prendre cet argent pour
sa boulangerie pourquoi parce qu'en
suisse une entreprise ne peut pas
recevoir de l'argent de plus de 20
personnes seules les banques seules les
entreprises qui ont une licence bancaire
peuvent faire ça donc eric a dû recevoir
l'argent à titre personnel augmentent et
son assurance vie pour pouvoir couvrir
les personnes qui lui avaient prêté de
l'argent en cas de problème et quand
j'ai découvert cette situation il ya à
peu près un an et demi deux ans on s'est
regroupé avec plusieurs plateformes de
financement participatif pour créer une
association et travailler échanger avec
le régulateur avec les politiques pour
essayer de faire évoluer ça on a analysé
tout ce qui se passait ailleurs dans le
monde et on a vu que tous les pays
ouvrez le monopole bancaire pour
permettre le financement participatif
après de nombreux mois de travail à
plusieurs
on a réussi la semaine dernière à avoir
une annonce du gouvernement qui a mis
fin à ce monopole bancaire en suisse
c'est un premier succès mais c'est pas
le seul pour rendre accessible
financement participent à tous on n'a
malheureusement pas la possibilité
d'avoir tous accès à une communauté tous
accès à des personnes qui s'engagent
pour nous soutenir comme eric et pour ça
et pour que le crowdfunding se développe
à l'échelle internationale il faut
quatre éléments principalement le
premier c'est utiliser la technologie
des plateformes technologiques des
changes entre des porteurs de projets et
des personnes qui souhaitent les
soutenir il faut un cadre juridique qui
soit favorable
on en a parlé la régulation est un des
piliers il faut des flux financiers qui
soient maîtrisés pour éviter la fraude
le blanchiment d'argent et la corruption
c'est un vrai risque dans le financement
participatif et il faut mobiliser des
communautés il faut les construire les
animer et c'est une tâche qui est
compliqué on a vu que le financement
participatif de projets et accessible à
des artisans à des pme
mais il a plein d'autres applications
une autre application c'est pour les
artistes
on a vu l'un des premiers chanteurs en
grégoire qui a financé son album
uniquement avec du financement
participatif
il en a vendu plus d'un million et
maintenant il en est à son quatrième
album
à chaque fois il a essayé de mobiliser
sa communauté pour le financer et pas de
passer par des solutions traditionnelles
une autre façon c'est pour des créateurs
des inventeurs qui peuvent proposer
leurs prototypes avant de la voir
finalisée alors communauté c'est le cas
des inventeurs d'un casque de réalité
virtuelle qui en ont vendu plusieurs
milliers et qui maintenant est
accessible au plus grand nombre
c'est également une façon de mobiliser
sa communauté pour co créé et pour faire
une étude de leurs besoins de leurs
envies c'est ce qu'a fait cette année
elon musk en mettant en prévente son
dernier modèle de voiture
il en a vendu plus de 325 mille personne
n'a vu ni la voiture ni a eu l'occasion
de l'essayer c'est une solution pour des
athlètes des sportifs aux derniers jeux
olympiques plus de 100 personnes de 14
pays ont participé à cette compétition
uniquement grâce au financement
participatif
c'est une solution pour les
gouvernements les communes les villes à
la fois pour consulter les citoyens pour
co-construire pour design et les
services publics mais aussi pour les
financer la semaine dernière la police
de rio dé janeiro a lancé une campagne
pour consulter les citoyens et pour
financer la sécurité avec la population
c'est une solution pour financer des
causes des projets directement et plus
ou moins d organisation pour donner du
sens à son investissement et pour avoir
de la transparence
c'est enfin une solution pour financer
la recherche scientifique de façon
indépendante transparente et ouverte au
plus grand nombre avec toutes ses
facettes du financement participatif on
a un doublement des fonds levés depuis
on atteint 34 milliards de dollars en
et cette tendance va continuer elle va
continuer à se développer pour trois
raisons la première c'est les nouvelles
technologies décentralisée qui vont
permettre de donner un accès au plus
grand nombre à cette source de
financement
le deuxième c'est la régulation qui va
s'ouvrir et qui va permettre dans de
nombreux pays de pouvoir faire cela
l'année dernière en chine qui est le
seul pays qui n'est pas représenté dans
34 milliard on estime qu'il ya eu à peu
près 100 milliards de financement
participatif
donc ça représente trois fois le reste
du monde
ça va se développer et j'aimerais que
vous reteniez quatre points de cette
présentation
le premier c'est que le financement
participatif ce n'est pas facile souvent
on a tendance à considérer que c'est
simple qu'on peut faire comme eric mais
ce n'est pas aussi simple que ça il faut
se préparer il faut construire et
raconter une histoire et au delà de la
construire et de la raconter il faut la
partager
il faut que la communauté s'engage la
relais face du buzz autour de notre
campagne
donc ça devient du partage d'histoire il
faut toujours penser qu'il ya les 4 c
dans une campagne de financement
participatif la communauté la cause la
confiance est la contrepartie est le
dernier point que j'aimerais que vous
reteniez et ça va être un voeu pour ma
présentation c'est que vous tous vous
pouvez soutenir des projets vous pouvez
soutenir on l'a vu en début de
présentation
eric et je vous invite à le rencontrer
après la présentation mais vous pouvez
soutenir d'autres projets vous pouvez
aussi réussir votre projet en passant
par du financement participatif et
j'aimerais que vous gardiez ça avec vous
merci
[Applaudissements]